okay so thank you for inviting and today
I'm going to talk about large Corner
facets in higher dimensions and
so my talk is half an hour but I have a
lot of things to cover so that
the end what we do makes sense for you
and that's why I'm gonna race through a
lot of stuff and I'm not going to give a
lot of details but you can come and talk
to me and Morgan after it so Shahara
this is about it for you
okay so this is a joint work with Tony
who is supposed to be here we'll be here
tomorrow her ghost is here somewhere
it's Sohail Morgan who's here and Artie
schweitman who was also supposed to be
here it's not here okay
so let's start from arithmetic
regressions like we all know what is it
like you have a sequence of numbers and
each next number is shifted uh by the
same amount from the previous number
and a classical or like well studied
problem in combinatorics and active
networks external common networks is to
find the size of the largest subset from
numbers one to n which avoids any cater
and alphabetic progression right okay so
first people started this question for k
equals three and
some like the first lower bound was by
veteran to gave
constructed a set with this density one
over two to the square root login
order and pretty much that's it nothing
else happened after that and then on the
upper bound side like what is the what
is the largest subset that you that
after that all the subsets of cater like
free thermometer progression set by
rough they have at least then this
density and then like there was a very
very long line of research and finally
like the Breakthrough of Kelly and
Michael this year showed that different
construction was almost optimal
so we were really happy here but then
the situation in for General K is
completely different uh so first ranking
generalized veterans result and got this
density where like there is a dependence
on one Overlook k
and then but on the other hand on the
upper bound side we only know like one
over log star density right
by similarities here okay
so
today I'm actually going to talk about
I'm going to focus on Corners which can
think of as higher dimensional
generalization of arithmetic
progressions in the sense that now you
don't shift your numbers in One
Direction you shift them in how many
dimensions you have so for
two-dimensional uh
corner it is just a set of three points
where you have a center and then you
shift it by the some amount towards the
along the x-axis and then by the same
amount along the y-axis
and then you can do this for K
dimensional
in K Dimensions when you're looking for
a K plus one points in N to the K again
you have a center and then you shift in
each Direction
okay and again you can ask the same
question can you find the set which what
is the largest set in N to the K which
avoids K dimensional Corners okay
okay and k equals three
so the first upper bond is by itase them
already and apparently this problem was
asked by Erdos so now we have a big
motivation to study this problem
and oops sorry here I think what they
had is again one Overlook star but I I
think yes it is one of our dog stuff and
then uh after a long while the first
sensible uh Bond was given by shreddov
which made the density to be one over
logic
and then on the lower bound side
again like we have the construction from
different because ap3 sets implied
Corner reset
and then
things are moving here but very slowly
so they went out here because the
constant on the higher order theorem is
2.8 and then linear one shrubman and 21
taking completely another approach
improved it to 2.4 and then green
analyzed their protocol better and then
got 1.8
okay so this is the situation for k
equals three for General k
we have for the upper bound side covers
this Bound Again log star density and
for which there are
after this there are a couple of other
proofs but still uh we are stuck on one
over long star and the lower bound side
is just what we have from ranking okay
and in this work I get a new Bond
it might be because it's coming from
whatever version of like regularity limo
that he proves but I actually
yeah so the the proof for covers it is
worse but I don't know the other proofs
they might be a bit better
because there is also aquatic Theory
proof um
right but there is another one after
that
I don't remember buy home
yeah there is also pulling out anyways
so the offer bones part is not my point
I'm also afraid this was gonna happen uh
yeah yes
all right so what we are going to do is
gonna give a better lower Bound for
General K but like not much better
all right so this is where
and in the other work other comments or
in the previous for not for these yeah
so this this is yes and I'm assuming
cases also true but this is
always yeah you can always translate it
but the the question is did you get
something better or not you get
essentially the same balance in this
route for this thing
okay so this is very becoming that's
where it's okay and
um
uh so here like the the bond that we
prove they essentially take the same
approach that lineal entrapment took by
looking at the corners problem from the
communication complexity uh point of
view and in which saying that there is a
communication complexity problem they're
actually nailing down the pro complexity
of that problem is equivalent to the
corners problem
um
okay so I'm gonna
describe what is the communication
complexity model that we're going to be
working on it's called number on
forehead it in k-party setting let's say
I have a function which is defined on uh
K dimensional Cube and takes blue
involves and I have K parties uh
Einstein by query and pick your favorite
two scientists I don't know any other
two apparently
um so they have
the inputs written on their forehead and
the setting is that they only see the
other ones
inputs they don't see their own input
and of course their goal is to compute
the function of the inputs and the way
the only thing that we're allowed to do
is to write on this Blackboard
um
by individually they have unlimited
computational power and the complexity
of model is how many bits for the most
input that we have to write so that we
figure out what is f on that input okay
so deterministic communication
complexity is like what is the I
actually said like
the numbers
bits written for the worst input for the
best protocol
uh okay
so let's say what is the problem for
which it is its complexity is exactly
so let's look at this following problem
I I have K numbers from one to n and my
function is I want to know whether they
sum up to n or not
and this is interesting problem from
communication complexity point of view
itself if you forget about the networks
because it has
constant cost randomized and we still
don't know how much exactly it's it's
deterministic and there is a chance that
this is actually a hard problem for
number one forehead which up until
yesterday I didn't know that exists and
one of us Shahar can prove that there is
a function that is hard for
deterministic but it's not hard
randomized
okay so this can be also such a function
that we don't know
but so the people who introduce this
problem genre first Lipton they actually
gave also the bones which were coming
from the corners problem and this is
exactly the situation that we have now
like on the lower Bond side we know that
we need at least local game bits and the
upper Bond side it's at most square with
login
and
they did this through reductions to like
combinatorial problems that like the
density problems the coloring problems
um
and I'm gonna go through some of them
like I'm gonna go to this direction uh
here because I want to talk about lower
bonds for this sorry upper bonds for
this problem
um
Okay so
but here like to do to go from here to
at least here we need to go we need to
reduce this problem to another
communication complexity problem
and let's look at that reduction now
so for that I need the second setting of
K party communication complexity where
every person has a number in hand so
they only see their own number but I
don't see others numbers
and
obviously number in hand is
okay okay I'm not going there it's not a
communication from Mexico
um
all right now I'm gonna show how does
exactly end in number one forehead
reduce to number enhanced equality with
where your promise that your inputs are
arithmetic progression
um so assume I have three parties always
and Bob Ali says X written over forehead
four plus Y and Charlie has said and now
like their goal is actually to make the
function to Output one so Alice can
guess what her what is the number
written of her forehead so that the
value is one and Bob can guess and then
Charlie can guess it's the number like X
Prime if x is equal to X Prime then the
function outputs one
um
so
Also let's look at this difference n
minus the sum and if this difference is
zero then our function outputs found
right
note that this difference is exactly the
difference that each person has from
Bayer guess
uh the real value from the real input
from the objects
so okay let's define this magic function
which is carefully chosen
um you'll see why
and all these guesses this functions
value with her guess input
so it becomes like P minus Delta and
then Bob guesses this and then Charles
Charlie guesses it with his input and
then in the end what we get is a free
term arithmetic progression because of
this magic function that we chose
um all right
so now oh yeah
[Music]
okay now what I have is that Alice has
this ball past this and Charlie has this
and they know that their inputs form
arithmetic progression right
and now I want to know whether this
Delta is zero or not meaning this AP is
Trivial or not
like all of these things are equal
if Delta is zero then my function
outputs one so in the end like what we
have seen is that okay if this function
outputs one then these things have to be
equal so
is it like obvious that this is the best
one
I mean if you can come up with something
which will give me a better reduction
then I'll be really happy
um
okay so so far they've reduced number of
foreign
exactly and to number in hand equality
with the promise that might uh inputs
are forming filter marketing progression
so the entire reason that I wanted to
show you is so that you see various
display current arithmetic progression
comes up
all right and then from this we can show
that the complexity of this problem is
actually equivalent to the complexity of
the coloring problem when my color
classes have to avoid uh cater
mathematic regression and since this is
supposed to be a half an hour talk from
which I have apparently only 15 minutes
I'm gonna avoid that but this is the
equality
and then if you have a coloring you can
find the set and these are the bonds
like this is the density version
so in the end what we see is that okay
lower bounds on my uh
set problem implies upper bounds on
number on forehead exactly
and uh
one like I already mentioned that parent
kept such a lower bound and from that
lower bound from backhand's lower bound
you can immediately get this square root
login
all right so I want to go over
there and construction very quickly
um
by the way this talk might go over time
at any point you are free to leave it's
a free country
so let's fix
q and d numbers such that Q to the D is
equal to n and
for each number from one to n I'm gonna
look at its base Q representation and
I'm going to think of it as a
D dimensional vector and then I'm going
to be working with this vectors
so assume I have three numbers which
form a pre-term arithmetic progression
and
I'm gonna look at their vectors
their vectors have to be
on the line there has to be a line
passing by them
and which means if that if
these things are forming
um
arithmetic progression then where
vectors can't be on the same sphere it
means if I
peak oops if I pick
some length and then look at what are
the points from my set that fall on that
sphere then they are definitely free of
preterm arithmetic progression
so and then I can argue that okay by
pigeonhole principle you can find a
sphere on which you have a lot of or
like whatever number I want
point and get some Bond okay
um
except
Israelis someone here should be doing
quiz wait like reggae because we I'm
lying somewhere here and where I'm lying
is
Baseline
and I claimed that if these three
numbers are forming arithmetic
progression then phase three should form
on the line because
because of basically carries like if you
look at one example
like if I take 1 12 15 and I look at
base 10 representation
then these are the three vectors and
they are obviously not on the left okay
so carries mess up low a lot and I feel
like
all of this work is just how to deal
with the care is better
all right so but this is not the end of
the story what you can do is say all
right how can I guarantee that I don't
have carries I can just limit the L
Infinity now I'm saying okay on each
coordinate I can be at most Q over 2
then I want to generate it this will
decrease my set but apparently it's
still good enough that gives you the
square root login menu
and you do pigeon hold and then choose q
and d carefully it you get this Bond
okay so resource Performance
Construction and then from this uh
you get as I said the order Square would
login protocol for
exact same
and then now you're like okay but I
would really like to maybe get a better
protocol which has better cost and then
One Direction it's like oh let me see
how can they make this better I can't it
seems really hard to make bear hand
better now we understand why but can I
what can I do else like another thing is
that this protocol is an existential
protocol like in the end of the day we
are just picking a pigeon something
whatever pigeons will give us right and
the first step would be to find
something which is explicit and this is
what uh
this is what lineal Peterson schweidman
did and
they did
oh
so okay fair protocol is just very
simple it's like you take
uh you do the reduction to NIH and then
each player like the first player sends
the length of the vector and then uh if
other players agree with the length the
output one otherwise zero but then they
have to deal with the carries and the
way that they deal with the carries like
one of the parties
explicitly communicates the entire carry
and
they're done and then they get face
bound which is exactly whatever Behrend
is getting
all right
then
denial and treatment where like wait a
second can we maybe do better because uh
we don't need to communicate the entire
care Vector we are in the number one
forehead model there is a lot of like
shared information going on can be used
at somehow and that's what essentially
they do
they realize that for a young like for a
random input the number of bits that the
player free needs to send player one so
that they see the carry is not actually
entropy of the carry Vector but the
entropy of K Vector given y right so
this decrease is already the amount of
communication happening so that they get
this 2.4 Improvement and this also
implies the
better larger Corner preset
all right so this was the situation oops
oh I forgot to say that later
uh green analysis area protocol better
and cut actually the 1.8
okay so this was all for K greater than
three and
sorry k equals 4 3 and what we do is for
General K so what can this do for K
greater than three obviously parent
still works every uh
anyways balancing Works
um
so for K greater one free ranking
generalized reference result and
reference construction by uh defining
higher degree progressions which you
called polynomial progressions and then
because I don't have really much time
I'm not gonna do really the all the
proofs but I can do it later if you want
so he looked at the degree and
polynomial progressions where degree m
one it was actually the arithmetic
progression one and then his idea was
that all right parent was saying if I
have three numbers and then I look at
their vectors then they don't lie on the
same sphere if I have a VAP and here if
I have K numbers and they form a k term
degree M polynomial progression if they
can't lie on the same sphere and now
using this idea like repeatedly I can
find the
set which is uh
degree M polynomial progression free and
then degree M over 2 and then recurs
until I find a bigger set of
which is free of arithmetic regression
which was the big one
okay
so ranking got
like
like this density
and then which is like more precise
latest
and this gives for
or k players for exactly n which gives
this
but then again we want something better
right and you can still argue that all
right let's make an explicit protocol as
linear P transcribement did for bear
hand and then try to improve it and
which is exactly what we did
so our explicit protocol it
sounds exactly the same reduction of
going from nof to NIH promise problem
equality promise problem
and then from that we go to the equality
Vector Problem by looking at the inputs
as again Vector is in Q to the D and
then from Vector problem we want to go
to uh
equality problem in numbering and with
promise that my numbers form a higher
degree progression
and by for that for this vectors we take
pair squares sorry
lengths
squared
and then doing this by increasing the
degree we eventually get to a high
degree polynomial progression which is
high enough for us so that this function
just becomes equality and then we can
just solve equality with by the
retrieval protocol of sending everything
so okay this everything that we find
here except again carries
and for Curious the way we deal with it
we deal with it here from coming to here
to here
and
what do we do they say all right if I
have these vectors and I want them to be
small so that they don't generate a
carry what I'm gonna do I'm gonna shift
them
and
so if there's like if I shifted in this
range vectors don't generate carries so
bear five
um
the way that we do like the protocol the
way it would work is like the first
player would send the first the shift
computes the shift and then sends it and
the other players see whether they need
to shift it by the same amount or not if
it's not the same amount then we already
know that the vectors are not equal and
so we can quit an output zero if they
are the same amount then we know that
okay we are fine and we can oops
we can go here and execute because
everything will be correct if I have
equality here then I will have equality
here as well
okay so the only thing here was that
the shift was costing us bits debit and
then
that actually grows
and in the end what we get is again the
same bound that one can get
the same number of bits
all right so the
the only thing left to do is actually
try to improve this as linear entrapment
did and
the way that we can improve is again we
can try to deal with the carries better
and again note that when we were
so the place that we dealt with Karis
was here and we are already in the NIH
model and we don't have any shared
information so we actually launched a
lot of information from coming here to
here and we can't improve here so the
what we have to do is to do better here
and
that's why
we don't go here to this reduction but
instead we go to another number on
forehead
problems from which then we go to this
vector
promise problem
and what is this problem again it's the
same problem except like you're now you
have vectors and you want to know
whether there each individual coordinate
sums up to it
um
and the
uh like
the Improvement is actually here like
this one minus
Sigma K this is K I don't know why it
doesn't show
all right I'm maybe gonna do the idea
very quickly and then that would be it
and you can ask me questions
all right
so
first again we want to use the shared
information that we have right
the first thing would be uh for one of
the parties to compute the carry string
and send it but now each value in the
carry string is a number from 0 to K
minus two and it will cost us T Times
log K bits which is too much
another now we have to improve that
um
now you can note something else that I
don't actually have to send my like
exactly the number
every time like from
uh
from the cave or a player's perspective
the carry string can be uh two
consecrative numbers it's either let's
say six or seven and it doesn't have to
send six entirely it can just send the
parity so it's enough for the
player to send only the parities of the
carry string and then from that each
player will have enough information to
reconstruct it
and so
in this way we will only be sent t-bits
which matches exactly what ranking game
also about explosive protocol game
and now this is where the advantage
comes up
oh okay you say we are sending debate
and uh so for the carry string there are
two to the the options right and now if
I have
if each input is if each carry string is
equally likely then I can't hope to
improve anything because I have to send
all the debits but it turns out that uh
for if you're summing up yeah
if you're summing up odd numbers then
the carry string zero zero zero zero
zeros is more likely and
thus you don't have to send all the bits
so by only like noticing this it already
gives you enough Advantage uh to save it
because uh
more one
two to the B fraction of your inputs are
like are happy with the all zero string
and that's like if you
if you do all the excruciating details
it works but the details
okay what we get is actually this so
if I forget this part this is exactly
what ranking gives us and our
Improvement is this part
and so T here is load k
and what is CK CK is a constant which
bit grows with K as at least but they
actually have a
explicitly what it is and it is very
interesting I wanted to cover that but I
couldn't but I can hint that it is
relate it it is some expression
involving uh Euler's exact numbers
that's like somehow it came up
and thus like this improved protocol
gives you improved k-dimensional corners
[Music]
um
that's a good question I I that would
mean like okay uh can I improve this
summer this I'm sorry God this is here
but I guess
don't say anything
I don't know
um
or it's too obvious of a problem it's
not our improved protocol in the end of
the day it's not actually very explicit
there is a part which in which we do a
probabilistic argument which is just
tiling and what if like we try to make
that stable so explicit this could also
this would need a new
technique new idea which might actually
improve the cost
and also give a new Bond on the corner
problem
and then the second one is of course
like try to narrow this gap for exactly
and also for chronography and either
come up with the new construction also a
new protocol or at the lower bump this
part seems scary but maybe with this
very
Kelly make a result maybe it's not I
don't know he should say you should say
but uh this one uh we can try to work
that's it
any questions
[Music]
um
what do you mean by removing because
we're moving in my view was avoiding the
communication complexity language
it would be interesting so how not when
you move to higher Dimensions than like
you actually do need to
I guess the whole point of me coming
giving a focus of two missing people to
also look at the communication
complexity Viewpoint because maybe that
will give us a new way of to try to
generate an idea which will yeah maybe
in the end you can formulate it as a
community first
but as sorry come networks proof I'll
explain it
so this is dated by shrive and we find
this equivalent version of compares to
it right yes much bigger yes
[Music]
um
no because it's just it's just this
equality thing which yeah it's just the
equality thing because like
I think nothing number one for it
because the number for or like when you
have big parties then like you have
stars and new stories not actions
right it's not any more questions
Google
papers